next question today hey David this is
from Carrie what do you think of this
new right-wing insult meme NPC NPC this
actually came up at politican during my
fake news debate so here is just like an
experiment I want to do first just to
see about this do you have any idea what
NPC means Pat oh god no I don't and I've
done limited research into it trying to
understand what the term means but I
know it's the latest alt-right trope
that's about it that's all I got so let
me explain to you and then I'll tell you
what what I think about it NPC stands
for non playable character okay if you
play video games how once again video
game culture is trying to install
terminology into society I don't know
but they are I also don't really
understand gamergate so this goes
hand-in-hand NPC is when you play a
video game there are characters that the
human player controls so like if you
play Super Mario Brothers you control
Mario or Luigi if you're playing a
two-player game the Koopas for example
are non playable characters there are
characters in the game the humans can't
control them and the reason that it
because becomes sort of an insult is
that the Koopas operate on this really
fixed and limited logic where they sort
of move towards Mario and try to touch
him which hurts him and they don't know
how to run away from the shells that you
throw at them they just replicate that
behavior unthinkingly over and over so
that's the analogy when you call someone
an NPC on the internet what you're
basically saying is they are not real
participants in the direction of the
discussion
they are just repeating lines they are
playing a script they are playing a
really their beta their beta and
predictable and unthinking that's what
the insult means you can't think on your
own this is a stunningly dumb meme does
anybody really think that these are
intelligent or clever phrases or
interesting critiques of society saying
that people you identify as beta are
NPCs and quite frankly if you see people
using this term my instinct would be to
pity them rather than to get angry I
would ignore them and for the most part
I mute them on Twitter at this point I
don't even know how many hundreds of
people I have muted but over the weekend
after the political debate we're roaming
millennial commented on what NPC is I
started getting a ton of tweets from
people saying I'm an NPC or that my
appearance on Jessica Peters Peterson
was NPC I just mute them all I just have
no time for this nonsense
yeah this all seems really silly to me
but I don't think the analogy really
stands up because sure in the first
couple levels you have those NPCs that
will just get hit by anything and die
and they won't really do much damage to
you but by the end you have like the
boss characters like Bowser to use your
Mario example yeah and and those guys
are pretty tough like they'll they'll
beat you a few times before you end up
yeah I'm conquering them but I think
still the critique would be that they
are behaving on pre-programmed logic and
not really thinking for themselves to
the extent that video game characters
think to themselves it is really really
dumb and I hope that it'll fade away
just like all of these other silly terms